all right i've been uh going through
a lot of voicemails i had over 600
voicemails waiting for me when i got
back from vacation and um i found one
guy i don't believe we've ever heard
from this guy before but maybe maybe
once before
uh who is convinced it's not going to be
august it might be september or october
definitely by january 1 donald trump
will be president again so says this
caller now remember if you want to call
the number is 219 to david p
take a listen to this
david paffman
how's it going my favorite demon rat
look i'm not a very smart man but it
doesn't take a genius to know that this
was a rigged election
trump is coming back and i don't know if
it's going to be in august september
october whatever
but it's going to happen
in fact by the new year trump will be
back in office and i can't wait to see
your faces when that happens
god bless trump
yeah so hearing the guy say demon rap
um
it actually does ring a bell i think
that this guy may actually have called
before
that's a delusional trumpist and so
again the question is it was going to be
march and then april and then may and
then august and then now it's august
september and now this guy's saying well
definitely by january 1st
one of two things could happen one is
they just push it further oh it's going
to be february it's going to be march
and then eventually it'll be like well
just vote for trump 2024 and that's it
it doesn't become violent
the other possibility is that at a
certain point these people go nuts and
they actually go out and do real world
violence in the streets and i hope that
doesn't happen that would be horrifying
if it did
i don't know which way it's more likely
to go but we did have that report
yesterday department of homeland
security is increasingly concerned
because of the calls to violence if
trump isn't reinstated that they are
seeing
from some of these completely delusional
unhinged trumpets i'm always hoping for
the outcome that skips the violence
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
restaurant owners
will be suing new york city and bill de
blasio over the indoor vaccine mandate
not all restaurant owners a group of
restaurant owners they say it puts an
undue
uh
undue influence uh undo undo a sort of
uh apparatus infrastructure that they
can't meet they're saying this is not
like checking an id
we now have to say is this a real
vaccine card
and they are suing because many of them
don't want to do it we'll talk about
that number two
a new report finds that 61 percent of
americans paid no federal income tax in
2020. what does this really mean are
these numbers surprising or not when you
understand how federal income tax works
and then lastly joe biden's approval is
down below 50 for the first time ever
during his presidency and i don't think
it's a surprise as to why that's
happening i think that there has been
some disastrous press for him over the
afghanistan situation although a
majority of americans agree with the
action that he took
but the lack of another big legislative
accomplishment so far combined with some
bad press about afghanistan i am not
shocked to see biden drop below 50 we'll
talk about what it means
the implications
and what the next year has to look like
if democrats want to have a shot at
retaining control of the house and
senate in 2020. all of those stories why
am i mentioning them because they're on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com and uh you will be
instantly able to get access to the
bonus show see you then